E aí
[Música]
se você já pensou numa experiência
internacional Já pensou em fazer uma
estrada no exterior Estados Unidos
Canadá o quem sabe não tipo de perguntar
ligado não dos países do continente
africano ou nos países da América do Sul
eu já sei estava a pensar no estágio tá
bom É sempre um lugar e desenvolvimento
e hoje em dia as empresas valorizam
muito a tal experiência internacional
porque isso faz parte exatamente daquele
profissional moderno do Futuro Está
habituado diferentes contextos a
trabalhar com diferentes pessoas
interculturalidad multiculturalidad
ambiente diversificado inovador
e o que significa e trabalhar no
estrangeiro
O que significa ultrapassar fronteiras
sair da nossa casa do nosso país
é que sabe o que que isso significa para
mim que você vai virar migrante
internacional
um pouco assustado não não fica eu vou
explicar eu já vi o vi Participei de
várias conferências palestras cursos e
posso dizer que a definição teórica do
migrante internacional é simplesmente
que uma pessoa vai sair do seu lugar de
residência ou a país de origem para
residir Ou pelo menos com o objetivo de
residir em um outro país portanto
ultrapassando fronteiras
internacionalmente reconhecidas por um
período de um ano
eu vou fazer uma estrada num período
superior a um ano fora de seu país
torna-se a um migrantes internacional
exatamente o migrante internacional não
é pura e simplesmente aquela pessoa que
vai trabalhar e serviços talvez fazer
trabalhos considerados menos
qualificados Emigrantes internacional é
tudo e qualquer pessoa que sai do seu
país de origem ou de residência habitual
o e obviamente que já deve ter ouvido e
utilizado outro steps isso também tem
uma razão
e o desenvolvimento acadêmico e também
Legislativa acaba por utilizar outros
termos para diferenciar alguns migrantes
também por uma questão de organização
Legislativa de uma forma mais fácil de
perceber por isso nos temos o tal
Imigrante requerentes de asilo refugiado
beneficiário de produção internacional
exilado e provavelmente já deve ter
ouvido até a palavra o tal expatriado
que é também o Imigrante apenas um uma
outra forma de falar
bom e como mencionei devido a minha
experiência profissional e acadêmica
esses conceitos a fazer ideias sempre me
pareceram até Claras mesmo a solução das
mais cinza antes eu conseguiria sempre
encontrar uma lógica para perceber qual
seria a política ou legislação a ser
aplicada a cada um dos Tais migrantes
internacionais
é mas tenho de confessar algo essa visão
começou a mudar no natal de 2020 quer
saber o que aconteceu no natal de 2020
eu passei eu já tô de 2020 uma grande
amiga minha que é portuguesa mas que não
é de Lisboa mora em Lisboa mas a sua
origem a sua família está na mensagem me
surpreendeu com uma grande com uma
grande constatação ela me liga e diz
Emily eu já sei o que é ser uma migrante
internacional
e eu vou dizer isso a proposta de facto
de que devido às restrições impostas
pela pandemia e também por causa do seu
próprio senso Cívico ela não foi visitar
os pais durante o natal e 2021
e por mais que eu percebi se a sua dor
percebi se o seu sofrimento de ter
ficado tanto tempo sem ver os pais eu
não recebia porque ela achava que a
partir daquele momento
eu conseguiria perceber No íntimo a
definição do que é ser um migrante
internacional hora ela tinha ficado em
Lisboa não sendo de Lisboa e ficado
presa em Lisboa
é presa em Lisboa longe das suas raízes
longe de tudo aquilo que ele é conhecido
longe durante aquele período de natal
daquelas comidas daquelas refeições que
só nossa mãe sabe fazer
e aquelas conversas que só no seio da
nossa família ou dos nossos conhecidos
da terra nos conseguimos perceber
é longe tudo aquilo que ele é conhecido
e caro numa Terra desconhecida e que
poderia ter até amigas viu sua amiga
dela eu estava aqui se ela precisasse
mas eu não era a sua família
e coisas assim que ela ainda me tem que
explicar para que eu possa perceber
portanto no fundo eu percebi que ela
estava certa ela estava a falar do que
era ser um migrante Nacional migrantes
internacional depois que ele chega no
tal país de acolhimento quando ele está
ali imóvel
E no meio das suas inseguranças dos seus
medos e das suas inquietações
o e coincidentemente foi isso que a
planta minha nos trouxe esse mundo
desconhecido muitas novas regras regras
diferentes às quais Não estávamos
habituados medos inquietações
e não faz progressivas exatamente novas
burocracias e você pode até me perguntar
o que que novo de pro classes tem a ver
com Os migrantes bom Sabe aquele exemplo
de fazer um mestrado nos Estados Unidos
Pois sabe onde que tem que ir para pedir
um contrato de água luz gás nos Estados
Unidos sabe com quem tem que falar sabe
onde procurar uma casa para arrendar
saber quais são os documentos que tem
que levar para pedir o número de
contribuinte
o número de Segurança Social americana
bom tudo isso só novas experiências e
novos profecias novas formas de se
adaptar ao novo
e já pandemia nos trouxe isso tivemos de
nos readaptar portanto nesse período
todos nós fomos de certa forma um pouco
imigrantes e migrantes Imóveis mas com a
mesma sensação medo insegurança sem ter
a certeza de quando Poderíamos voltar a
ver os nossos entes queridos
é mas é importante também fazer uma
ressalva obviamente que a pandemia
afetou a todos e todas de forma
transversal todos os seus medos Todos
estavam inseguros não sabemos o que nos
esperavam mas é importante verificar e
para os imigrantes talvez esses medos
Essas inquietações eram mais fortes mas
prementes isso porque além do medo de
ficar doente Imaginem a insegurança de
pensar que por alguma razão o seu
instinto migratório poderá influenciar
no tratamento que irá receber no meio de
uma crise sanitária
é exatamente estatuto migratório a tal
possibilidade de estar em situação
regular ou não E acredite irregularidade
não significa apenas entrar de forma
ilegal um país significa não ter
oportunidade por exemplo de renovar uma
autorização de residência simplesmente
porque não tinha vaga insuficientes ou
porque o serviço ficou fechado de vida
pandemia
é E essas inseguranças esses medos
acompanharam sim os imigrantes de forma
geral em todo o mundo obviamente que cá
em Portugal houve uma evolução positiva
por exemplo está os despachos que
colocaram os imigrantes como sujeitos de
direitos com pessoas
E essas pessoas que começaram a ter
acesso a coisas simples como
possibilidade de ter um número de utente
no Centro de Saúde
a possibilidade de pagar taxas em quais
circunstâncias que os Nacionais O até em
termos de gratuidade de vida para anemia
a possibilidade de abrir uma conta
bancária possibilidade de contratar
serviços essenciais a água luz gás e
essas são e seguranças que os nacionais
por vezes não conhecem o conhecem de uma
outra forma
e essa pandemia
de certa forma conseguiu nos dar essa
percepção
e quem não tentou ir a um banco sem
saber se poderia entrar seria limite se
o horário do banco estava a funcionar
igualmente as Finanças como resolver as
questões cartão de cidadão inspirado
caducado como devo renovar Será que vão
abrir a possibilidade de fazer online
Será que não essas inseguranças nos
tornaram iguais mas novamente às
inquietações dos Migrantes continuaram e
continuarão pouca sem fazer nenhum juízo
de valor esses Imigrantes demoraram para
chegar no discurso político
e se lembrarem de muitas vezes que é
múltiplo Fernandes foram as televisões
eles falavam dos seus nacionais se
usarmos Portugal como exemplo Porque os
portugueses vão ter a passar a alegria
porque nós portugueses somos
disciplinados e vamos conseguir porque é
isso será uma prova mas nós iremos ter o
nosso verão vamos salvar o Natal o Natal
português
o e Os migrantes e os estrangeiros
estavam nas frentes de batalha a fazer
também a prestação de serviços
essenciais o mesmo a trabalhar nos
hospitais nos serviços de saúde eles
também tinha medo e eles também queriam
ser disciplinados eles também queriam
ultrapassar essa pandemia
e novamente tivemos boas notícias EA
possibilidade de ter um migrante de novo
dentro das atenção política como por
exemplo a possibilidade de imigrantes
que não tenham inscrição no serviço
Nacional de saúde onde poderem ser
vacinados esperança
a esperança é uma palavra essencial no
momento de pandemia
é mas é isso foi nesse momento enquanto
nós conhecemos agora o que é sem
quitação ao muitos migrantes
internacionais que vivem constantemente
dessa situação e essa foi a maior ideia
e o profundo pensamento que tive quando
a minha colega partilhou a sua
constatação
e ela me ensinou algo tão simples e
profundo e que hoje gostaria de
partilhar convosco e eu aprendi com ela
aqui o migrante internacional é muito
mais de ti alguém que ultrapassa
fronteiras por um período de um ano isso
é a migração internacional o migrante
internacional é simplesmente a pessoa a
pessoa que um qualidades ou defeitos
luta cada dia contra suas inquietações
os seus medos para buscar algo melhor
e esse algo melhor independe de qual
tenha sido a motivação que o fez sair do
seu território do seu país de origem ou
de residência habitual pode ter sido uma
questão familiar porque casou com o
estrangeiro e foi viver com essa pessoa
pode ter sido uma questão de estudo o
tal mestrado nos Estados Unidos uma
questão profissional uma oportunidade de
trabalhar numa empresa grande
internacional fora do seu país um
simplesmente porque foge de uma guerra
ou de uma perseguição por causa de uma
opinião política todas essas pessoas são
migrantes e apesar das imensas
diferenças e suas que sejamos políticas
e legislativas o que une essas pessoas
além do facto de atravessarem fronteiras
e internacionalmente reconhecidos são
seus medos e inquietações
é Mas acima de tudo a coragem de
enfrentar o novo com esperança de que
nesse novo lugar encontraram algo de
positivo um trabalho familiar pais
Ah e por isso aqui hoje aproveita para
deixar esse convite um convite de
reflexão um convite de pensarmos no
Imigrante como uma pessoa
é o melhor dizendo as 280 milhões de
pessoas que vivem fora do seu país de
origem ou de residência habitual que
lutam contra preconceitos burocracias
medos inquietações e isso é a Flick e
esta reflexão que constaria convidar a
cada um de nós para fazermos durante
essa pandemia
o e deixarmos de ver a pandemia apenas
como um problema que é um problema sério
de saúde pública Mas também como uma
oportunidade uma oportunidade para
migrar umas ideias aceitarmos os
diferenças e reinventarmos novas formas
de convivência que ultrapassam a
utilização de meios tecnológicos para
nos comunicar podem chegar ao convívio
entre pessoas mesmo que de origens
diferentes mas de forma igual porque
afinal o que somos estrangeiros e
nacionais não somos todos pessoas
sujeitos de direito e merecedores
designe andares
e vamos então Rio formular ideias de
grávidas
é muito obrigada a
[Aplausos]